Do you think that there's a right number
of children to have as you're saying
that?
That popped in my head.
I.
I come from a good number
and the reason for that,
if you have one child,
it's like I'm not saying,
well that's terrible man.
Like what the Hell is wrong with you?
That's hard to have one child because
children first of all socialize each
other and they amuse each other and so
we've found.
So we have two kids and then my wife
also took care of a couple of neighbor
kids that actually in some ways made
things easier because the kids will just
run off and amuse themselves and then
what you have to be is around when they
have a problem,
but they don't want you around and you
don't necessarily want them around.
You have adult things to do right?
With one child you've got the problem of
having to amuse the child all the time
and the child has the problem of not
having siblings to hash things out at,
at a peer to peer level.
And I think that maybe that one of the
reasons the overprotected child,
you know,
going to university phenomena has
emerged is because children are now
mostly produced by older couples,
so who are more intent on doing
everything right for them.
But they also don't have enough siblings
so they're not getting sorta,
you know,
they're like puppies that haven't had
enough rough and tumble play with other
puppies.
And they're really like that.
I mean,
and that's not good.
We know from the animal developmental
studies,
like even with rats,
I'm social animals don't do that well
unless they have peers to get into it
with,
you know,
and a lot of socialization takes place
between peers and so.
So I would say to kids minimum because
well then you have kids and they can
amuse each other and maybe three is
nice,
but one is,
one is I do not believe that one is
easier than two.
I don't believe that.